[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
hip hop is a good vibe all right episode
your best friend Harry has a brother
episode
213 with home team today we got
everybody in the house oshana Ellsworth
saw snake but David and we got a bunch
of things to talk about by the way let
me give you some uh stories here before
we get into it last night was a weird
night for me because after we're done
with our meeting at 11 o'clock down uh
Tampa Bay is down 16-3 I go upstairs now
Leo starts playing by the way shout out
to Andy very happy birthday Leo starts
blasting me you remind me by the way let
me give you credit uh and then Leo text
me says did you see what's going on I'm
like what's going on he says Tampa Bay
is down six with two minutes left and
Brady's got the ball I'm like what and
they end up winning 17 to 16. the only
time he's done that twice in his career
that time and the time against the
Falcons when he made a comeback crazy
shout out to Barry
because I was at Pat's house right a
late night strategy meeting doing a lot
of work getting ready for 20 2023 and
I'm four minutes late getting home so I
miss this but the the guy that's two
doors down the garage is open and
there's like several cars you know bad
cars that are out in front and
everything and they're smoking cigars
and they're in their standing they're
kind of animated and it was raining a
little bit but I stopped and got out and
said he said hey Jeff so what's going on
he says we just saw the most amazing
company crazy yeah and they were just
getting into it like a playoff game I
love it so we got a lot of things to
cover let me tell you the stories we got
to cover we got to cover the Twitter uh
files that's being talked about all over
MSNBC CNN you know CBS ABC they're all
talking about wait do you know by the
way do you know the actual amount of if
you know it don't say it do you know the
actual amount of time
that CBS ABC CNN MSNBC has spent talking
about the Twitter files do you know the
time I do not know that I'm going to
give you the time and you're not gonna
believe it I'm gonna get better I want
people to guess the number in the chat
room if you're watching this I want you
to guess and then we'll go into it okay
okay so uh uh Elon Musk on a live that I
was supposed to be part of that I missed
because of a flip and fly coming back
from Phoenix seriously I was uh but
anyways he talked about Suicidal
Thoughts we'll talk about that if
Twitter collapses they say Tesla will be
right behind that's an Insider story
there's a rubini warns uh uh the mother
of all economic crisis Looms
if anybody knows rubini he has an open
invitation to be on the podcast we want
to know we got some questions for him
fed to weigh higher interest rates next
year while slowing rate uh Rises this
month Tom's got some commentary on that
saving great plunges to lowest level
since 2005. that's not a good sign by
the way that's 17 years CNN boss hired
extra security after cutting hundreds of
Staff members I got some thoughts on
that apple and Amazon resume advertising
on Twitter uh startup uh uh backed by
Tesla investor promises ready 300 000
flying cars by
2025. this is not more complicated than
the Toyota Corolla four intent consumers
believe housing market will crash times
got them some data on that fewer
tourists and less spending in Las Vegas
as inflation takes toll musk responds to
Kanye West Adams got some thoughts Nike
permanently dumps Kyrie Irving
Jean-Pierre who's our Frontier that
responded about the Twitter Vinnie's got
some thoughts on that and a couple other
things that's going on this guy named
Michael avenatti who at one point people
thought he's going to run for office is
now going to jail for 14 years we'll
talk about that as well if there's any
other stores you want us to talk about
please post it here okay so now I want
to put this up there on how many seconds
oh second I thought you said time so now
I already know seconds no bro 20s how
many seconds how many seconds it's not
even let me put this up there too I'm
going to try to send it to you everybody
here is going to be shell shocked when I
give this number okay I just send it to
you Rob I don't know if you see it
uh uh if you're not seeing are you
seeing it or no
okay hang on let me just text it to you
I'm sorry Malik next time I'll I'll
correct it all right Andrew shout out to
Andrew Schultz I'm giving you your new
nickname you should see this okay the
time did you guys say your time or did
you see it or not no I sort of got it
okay what's your time
well you kind of let the cat out the bed
six seconds what were you gonna say I
was gonna say minutes I'll just say
three I was gonna say three minutes but
the fact that you slipped up what were
you 20 seconds I wrote a town right here
my witness 10 minutes 10 minutes over
all three networks over all networks Tom
this is not just one network 60 minutes
so check this out put this up there and
tell me if this makes any sense seconds
guys that's all they spend can you make
it in a way so we can there you go guys
seven seconds is all they spent on
Sunday shows though CBS but this is
right after the announcement is made on
Saturday if this was anything everybody
would be on time if a small little
comment came out anything about anything
on the right or Republicans they would
have spent the entire day talking about
it seven seconds on this so have you
guys followed the story closely have you
read all the tweets by MattyB I have I
have seen a I've seen a bunch of what
the Matt TYB has posted in a sub
background should we just get into that
first yes I feel like we're already in
it all right so if you can pull up the
Tweet thread so we can read it while
you're doing that I want to read the
article from Wall Street Journal uh
musk's release of internal emails uh
relating to Twitter's 2020 censorship
and news by any definition even if the
mainstream media dismisses it there will
be many threats to unspool
as more is released by a couple of
points are already worth making the
first is that musk would do the country
a favor by releasing the documents out
all at once for everyone to inspect a
second point is who's uh for rep rokana
the California Progressive Democrat who
warned Twitter in 2020 about the Free
Speech implications and political
backlash of censoring New York Post
story about Hunter Biden's laptop a
third point is the confirm confirmation
of the central role that former spies
played in October 2020 and framing the
hunter Biden story in a way that made it
easier for Twitter and Facebook to
justify their censorship recall that
former Democratic intelligence officials
James Clapper and John Brennan let the
Spooks in issuing a public statement
suggesting that the laptop may have been
hacked and its content was Russian
disinformation okay so do you guys know
how many days it took for CBS to admit
that the hunter Biden story was a real
story do you guys know the exact date
have they done it yet they have do you
know how long it took 769 days
it took them 769 days to say the story
about Hunter Biden Israel it took him a
half a second to say Russian collusion
was real and it was fake okay so think
about why people don't trust all the
stuff that's taking place with media so
let's go through this threat together if
you want to zoom in
and folks if you haven't read it I'm
going to read it uh zoom in a little bit
more if you could there you go should we
explain up front Who Matt taibi go ahead
tell the audience no he's just Rolling
Stones he's a Rolling Stones journalist
journalist you're not a republican not a
republican by far
um but you know I would put him in more
in the common sense Camp he's not I
think he's more left than he is right
and he said he and he got a legitimate
investigative report actual reporter
which that word is so loose these days
but in fact he got access through Elon
yeah to get all this information so what
Elon is doing he's going and getting a
bunch of these guys to come join the
team which is great I love what he's
doing so let's read through it okay so
thread the Twitter files um look how
many likes I got by the way 373 000
likes 155 000 retweets what you're about
to read is the first installment in a
series based upon thousands of internal
documents obtained by sources at Twitter
the Twitter files tell an incredible
story from one side of the world's
largest and more most influential social
media platform it is a Frankenstein tale
of a human built mechanism grown out of
control of a design of its designer
Twitter and its conception was a
brilliant tool for enabling soap mass
communication
making a true real Global conversation
possible for the first time in an early
conception Twitter more than lived up to
its mission statement giving people the
power to create and share ideas and
information instantly without barriers
as time progressed however the company
was slowly forced to add those barriers
some of the first tools for controlling
speech were designed to combat the likes
of spam and financial fraudsters makes
sense so it's important to point out
there's no question about that slowly
over time Twitter staff and Executives
began to find more and more users for
these tools Outsiders began petitioning
the company to manipulate speech as well
first a little then more often than
consistently by 2020 requesting requests
from the connected actors to delete
tweets were routine one executive would
write to another more to review from the
Biden team the reply would come back
handled if you look at that email
there's five people right there Pat
what's the date
October 24 2020 a week before election
yep
one very good point number nine
celebrities and unknowns alike could be
removed and reviewed at the behest of a
political party again this is another
one to click on it click on that picture
uh you zoomed in a little bit too much I
grabbed the first one under SI defer to
safety on the high profile second one
okay an additional report from DNC this
is now on the 25th they're replying back
to it okay let's go back to the email uh
number eight go to number nine and the
high profile second one was James Woods
this was I saw that go number 10 go
number ten both parties had access to
these tools for instance in 2020 request
from both the Trump White House and the
Biden campaign were received and honored
however the system wasn't balanced it
was based on contacts because Twitter
was and it's overwhelmingly staffed by
people of one political orientation
there were more channels more ways to
complain open to the left well Democrats
than the right by the way people need to
know 99 of employees at Twitter donate
to the Democratic party it's not it went
from 96 it's at 99 remember after the
midterms we broke down yeah you know
each of the big Tech Silicon Valley uh
the way that they sway politically and
it was yeah all the big actors right
Facebook meta this that yeah it was all
90 plus resulting slant and content
moderation uh decision is visible in
documents you're about to read however
it's also suspended multiple current and
former high-level executive okay there
are more
the Twitter files part one how and why
Twitter blocked the hunter Biden laptop
story in October 14 2020 New York Post
published Biden's secret emails and
expose based on the contents of Hunter
Biden's abandoned laptop okay Twitter
took extraordinary steps to suppress the
story removing links and posting
warnings that it may be unsafe they even
blocked its transmission via direct
message a tool
um hither too
that's how you know he's a real
journalist he uses words like hitherto
hitherto White House White House
spokespur spokeswoman Kelly mechanic
Haley
confusing was locked out of her account
for tweeting about the story prompting a
few serious letter from Trump campaign
after Mike Khan was seated at least
pretend to care for the next 20 days by
the way she wasn't just the White House
spokeswoman she was the press secretary
that is insane to me kellyanne McCann
Haley mcenany I'm sorry sorry
she has been locked out from her account
for simply talking about the New York
Post story all she did was cite the
story and firsthand report it has that
has been reported by other outlets and
not disputed by the campaign uh uh Biden
campaign I need an answer immediately on
when and how she will be unlocked I also
don't appreciate how nobody on his team
called me regarding the news that you'll
be censoring news articles like I said
at least pretend to care for the next 20
days okay let's go to the next one
request on October 14th yeah so Twitter
uh okay there you go this led the
publicly public policy executive
Caroline Strom to send out a polite to
WTF query several employees note noted
there was tension between the comps
policy teams who had little less control
over moderation and the safety trust
teams can you click on and see what that
one says so safety and Trust as a team
had more power than communication it's
in the same time okay go back to it
let's wrap it up there's only four more
interesting folks I'm reading this
assuming some of you guys maybe haven't
read all of them uh number 21 strom's
notes returned the answer that the
laptop story had been removed for
violation of the company's hacked
material policy okay keep going down
although several sources recalled
hearing about a general warning from
federal law enforcement that's uh that
summer about possible foreign hacks
there's no evidence that I've seen of
any government involvement in the laptop
story in fact that might have been the
problem the decision was made at the
highest level of the company but without
the knowledge of Jack Dorsey wow with
former head of legal policy and Trust
Vijaya got a plank a key role
interesting that they're skipping Jack
Dorsey to even ask the CEO founder of
the company they just freelanced it is
how one made one former employee
characterize a decision hacking was the
excuse but within a few hours pretty
much everyone realized that wasn't going
to hold but no one had the guts to
reverse it
and last but not least you can see the
confusion and the following lengthy
exchange which ends up including Gad and
former trust and safety Chief Joel Roth
comes official Trenton Kennedy writes
I'm struggling to understand a policy
basis for making this unsafe can you
click on that can you click on that zoom
out a little bit okay Trenton I'm
struggling to understand the policy
basis for making this unsafe and uh I
think the best explainability argument
for this externally would be were
waiting to understand if the story is
the result of hacked materials we'll
face hard questions
bunch of people on the bottom okay keep
going go to the next one if there's any
I think uh maybe one or two left 25
26. by this point everyone knew this was
[ __ ] said one former employee but the
response was essentially uh to ER on the
side of continuing to ER okay keep going
down
former VP of global comms Brandon Borman
asks can we truthfully claim that this
is part of the policy go a little lower
to which former deputy General Jim Baker
seems to advise staying the non-course
because caution is warranted
a fundamental problem with tech
companies and kind of moderation many
people in charge of free speech of
speech no care little about speech and
have to be told the basics of Outsiders
and one humorous exchange on day one
Democratic Congressman rocana reaches
out to God to gently suggest shiha she
hop on the phone to talk about the
backlash re-speech kind of was the only
Democratic official I could find in a
files who expressed concern okay I mean
we can go more and more you can unstop
it at this point we've gone through all
of them Tom what are your thoughts when
you see something like this so this is
an organization that doesn't know what
free speech is and basically they had
become politicized and that's an
objective statement just by reading this
uh and Kana was correct he said listen
free speech is the ability to to
peacefully assemble and present your
um your point of view you know it used
to bother me terribly when I was in
college and I would see and I think it
was in hot in Ohio uh these Nazi groups
um like a club you know more than a club
in their little brown shirts will come
out and get together and hold a little
bit of a rally and speak and I just just
think it's just so wrong to hear that
but it was free speech age so you would
see that with your own eyes you'd see
knots no no I was I was watching the
coverage I was watching the coverage and
I would say wow I don't like what
they're saying this is really terrible
this is this a lot of people feel hurt
by this but it's like but the price of
free speech is Free Speech they're not
armed they weren't tearing up towns and
I think what has happened here is is
companies have become politicized and
it's becomes a communication Army and I
find this to be really Illuminating
especially when they get down they start
talking about free speech and then they
start talking about external
defensibility that tells you that adults
in the room knew that they had trouble
with what they were doing Tom what what
is the not telling the CEO this is the
biggest like imagine like oh we didn't
think we need to share this with you
something small happened yesterday I'm
like how come I didn't know about it but
on a situation like this do you think
Dorsey wants to know something like this
this is the biggest story that's going
to go out you don't call the CEO of the
company look
Dorsey if you take a look at Dorsey over
the last year he's had extended periods
of absence didn't he wasn't he like on
an extended Retreat somewhere he was
very focused on crypto square that was
he was right he had shown up things
going on but he was also out of the
country for a while and there is
something to be said about me walking
around your own organization Pat you
fled and been investor in several
organizations at the same time What is
the difference for you to be on site
walking around versus like emails and
zooms and everything else it's different
when it's on site you can kind of sense
things you get the little side
conversations and I don't think Dorsey
was getting any of that and they even
said uh we kind of freelance this and
didn't tell the boss they openly said it
yeah to me I first of all I don't
understand the concept of a CEO being on
vacation for three four months and you
not you shouldn't be a CEO if you want
to do that step down that's not
something you should be doing but
anyways if that's story what are your
thoughts about this when you see this so
you know there's a couple different
things that uh that I'm kind of
ruminating in my head number one they're
using the term bombshell
I don't think it's a bomb show meaning
was anybody shocked that the people at
Twitter were limiting free speech I
don't think anybody is completely
shocked by that I think that's the
reason that Elon and we all understand
why Elon said all right I gotta kind of
step in and be
um a freedom of speech Advocate and
that's the reason he bought Twitter
let's not forget that Elon Musk voted
for who in 2020
voted for Joe Biden I'll repeat that
Elon Musk voted for Joe Biden so it
should it almost shows the independence
and the the good nature of Elon he could
say hey look I could not support Trump
and not support what he stands for but
at the same time I can be sort of an
equal opportunist and an Umpire and say
this was wrong
right that because it's ultimately this
comes down to Elon Musk I think we all
would agree would this story have leaked
or what Matt tybe had access to these
Twitter files if not for Elon Musk would
you agree with that Pat
well you said of course you said
bombshell it was it's merely an
accusation subject for debate that's
spinning around the view and everything
else that are not really news
organizations but maybe it's not a
bombshell but it certainly is a
validation wouldn't you agree I I agree
I think it's something that this is
essentially the reason why Elon Musk
bought Twitter one of the reasons it's
freedom of speech you saw that he's
brought back Trump but Trump didn't want
to go back on there he's brought back
Kanye who has now sort of canceled
himself at this point he brought back
Tate he's bringing people back that
should have never left Twitter I guess
my question is
if everything would have played out and
freedom of speech would have been you
know allowed how much would that have
moved the needle of the election talking
about it's a question about making a
point how about you ask yourself what do
you think well I there what I'm trying
to distinguish is freedom of speech
information circulation I think we can
all agree upon that versus a totally
separate topic election fraud election
deniers freedom of speech this is part
of Elections you don't suppress that
information but that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm I'm stating is that
freedom of speech disinformation is not
actual election fraud does it is it
limiting information yes we're on the
same page there but the two are separate
that's what I think wait wait wait no no
but stay there so you asked a wonderful
question why don't you answer your own
wonderful question what's your question
I said how much of this actually played
part of the election yeah I mean we all
saw what happened with Hillary when
James Comey came out and basically said
and I agree okay
and you know allegedly that could have
swayed the electorate right but I I
don't know I mean it's not like where
they're counting the battle you can't
play that game I'm I'm asking a question
but but here's the question if you if
you're asking a question of us you ought
to be able to answer that question
yourself so because I'll give you my
answer okay but but here's what I'm
saying yeah tell me what is the actual
Hunter Biden laptop story meaning I I
personally don't think that Hunter Biden
is his evil henchman that's making all
these deals behind around the bush Pro
answer your own question you just asked
I'm your answer to your own question I'm
saying that whatever happened with
Hunter Biden okay and Twitter was wrong
and should have not been suppressed at
the same time that was not election
fraud bro you still are not answering so
you do you realize what it is to ask
somebody a question that you're not
willing to answer yourself I asked let
me question go ahead let me put the
question you said do we need to go back
and show you what you asked how much of
this would have impacted the election
answer your own question I don't know
that's the whole point but you can't say
I don't know could it have moved the
needle would it have moved the needle in
Arizona would it means
I don't know honestly Adam I think I
think you you have a belief under there
and you just don't want to say it you
started to talk about James Comey in the
emails and we can also go back at Bush
versus Gore bush had a drunk driving
conviction and it came out less than two
weeks ahead polls moved you've been you
didn't just turned 18 yesterday and just
start voting you've been around several
elections and you see how these things
move voters they do you can answer your
own question and you brought up you guys
are missing my point I'm saying that
information should have been circulated
agreed could that have moved the needle
yes possibly definitely but that is not
election fraud election fraud is a
separate topic all these elections all
the lawsuits that Trump went to to each
and every single Court okay were struck
down and lost okay so you guys are
trying to conflate Hunter Biden with the
election so a conspiracy of media yeah
let me keeps information from the voter
that's not from yeah so let's let's
let's no that's suppression it's not
from it's voter suppression so your
suppression the vote let's unpack let's
unpack this a little bit okay let's
unpack this a lyrical what you just said
you open up a can of worms you ask the
question that maybe I should have asked
the question but you asked the question
so if you ask the question you got to
own the question so no I don't I'm I'm
asking you guys the question you answer
the question but no if you if you do ask
a question like that you have to be able
to also answer the question you're
asking so let's let's let me give you
the answer to the question to say you
know would it have really and I love
because you know I watch so much CNN the
last couple days okay the last two three
days
can you do me a favor go on CNN's
YouTube channel and then go on msnbc's
YouTube channel go on CNN's YouTube
channel just go to YouTube and go to CNN
I want to show you hey John Malone you
say no no you're right there right
you're fine so hey John Malone or Chris
and Lucio click on videos for me and
zoom in a little bit so we can all see
it all right so that's four hours zoom
out a little bit so all the videos are
on the same page okay so first one is
about what she's signing off last one
how sweet yeah Chasing Life
yeah
so watch this reporter shows how China's
zero covet policy no problem Trump uh
Russia another story Pence about Trump
keep going another story where's Twitter
keep going keep going keep going still
no Twitter story keep going keep going
keep going no Twitter story keep going
keep going keep going no Twitter story
keep going keep going keep going no
Twitter story we're at two days down
we're at a Sunday night keep going keep
it there's no story on everything by the
way the only reason you don't talk about
it is because you know it has that kind
of influence so let's let's I can do the
same thing with MSNBC CBS ABC everybody
fine let me let me go to the other part
about would it have had any impact it
was on its way for being the most viral
tweet ever on Twitter that's how crazy
this Twitter Twitter was tweet was by
New York Post before they shut it down
it was on fire going viral the only
reason it was going viral is because
everybody was interested to see if this
man who's about to be our president is
using his card of presidency to steal
money or get money from others that is a
valid concern for people to ask people
who go into politics for a long time and
become rich concerns everybody from both
sides left right or the middle a
politician shouldn't go from making 140
Grand year to being worth 140 million
dollars or 20 million dollars or 50
million dollars there's something that
happened there now so to answer the
question did it have an impact everybody
who has Common Sense knows it had an
impact could it have flipped of course
it could have flipped now let's talk
about the uh the war that you're saying
election fraud let's let's unpack what
election fraud really means what is
election fraud I think I think the the
part that you're thinking about election
fraud is ballots and stuff ballots
correct that's no no but that's not just
election fraud election fraud is
multifaceted betrayal is betrayal
one-dimensional or is betrayal have 20
different dimensions to it betrayal has
I can you can betray me 20 different
ways it's not just one way to betray me
betrayal is not just about talking
behind my back and telling me stuff that
I betrayal doesn't mean you steal from
me betrayal doesn't mean you flirt with
my girl but Trail has 20 different
dimensions to it right okay Electro
fraud has election fraud has multi
different dimensions to it electoral
fraud sometimes referred to as election
manipulation voter fraud or vote rigging
Dr election manipulation which happened
voter fraud or vote rigging involves
illegal interference which they did with
the process of an election which they
did either by increasing the vote share
of a favorite candidate which they did
depressing the voucher of a rival
candidate which they did according to
this definition there is electorate oral
fraud so now
you get involved in Twitter and you're
telling an organization that's 99
percent funding one side how to protect
you and this guy becomes president let
me tell you why a guy in Mar-A-Lago is
furious sitting there saying what the
hell am I doing wasting four years of my
life in the in my 70s where I should be
the president today finish up my second
term love or hate me I could have gotten
my job done but you guys got this other
guy because there was election fraud
through social media company I didn't
say ballots
I didn't say any of that stuff this is
proof so for people to say ah it is what
it is it's just a non-story every CBS
ABS anything that I see anybody talking
about it onto any it's not a story from
the past it's just this it's not a big
deal yeah this is the kind of stuff why
today do you know who's the number one
journalist in the world today it's a guy
named Elon Musk do you know who's the
number one journalistic organization in
the world effectively today in just six
weeks of him running it it's called
Twitter the way he's running it we're
about to drop some news they're doing
more journalism than CNN CBS ABC NBC all
of those cats including Fox all of them
combined Twitter's doing more
investigative journalism than any of
those five cats combined and it's ran by
citizen journalists
shout out goes to them and for people
who were frustrated and upset for
something to be this if you're about to
marry a girl that I've known for a while
and you're about to propose to her and
you and I are boys I'm talking boys from
second grade okay I know this girl
and you ask me Pat I'm about to propose
is there anything I need to know and I
know some stuff that you need to know
about her okay and I really really and
this is the kind of stuff you should
know okay religious stuff
imagine I don't keep that keep that from
you and I don't tell you
six years later two years later you find
out from somebody else but you're
already married it's too late we're
married to Joe Biden right now we don't
have a choice
and then I tell you and he said you say
Pat what the f why would you not tell me
this I said bro this was two years it's
an old story man it's what she did 13
years ago it's what was seven years ago
who cares who makes it different anyways
right now you're married she's pregnant
and you guys are having a ton of fights
right now you said if I would have known
I would have never married her that's
how America feels right now that's
exactly how America feels right now they
feel like somebody had Intel on a girl
that were getting ready to marry but
they didn't want to tell him until after
they were married and they were pregnant
already great Point that's the
frustration people have and it's very
painful and I understand their
frustration and at the same time
we still have to be leaders responsible
and move on every it's it's a very weird
dynamic like living in the past we got
the information now we know who's
[ __ ] now we know who's dirty now we
know who's playing the games great we
know who the actors are let's move on
and make sure this doesn't happen to us
again how do we do that that's my
interest my interest isn't sitting here
bitching and complaining and whining and
let's change the Constitutional and I'm
not I'm not that guy all I'm saying is
this matters this is important they
effed up they lie to you they
manipulated they backstab you and they
laughed at your face and said who cares
anyways it's too late let's move on
[ __ ] you don't play those games with
people especially not in a country
called United States of America and
anyways a great point I'm gonna make I'm
gonna make two points uh when you when
we first started off you said about the
seven seconds all combined and we're
kind of like like in shock but is it
really shocking that they're all boys
and I'm gonna quote Good Fellas when
DeNiro tells young Henry Hill he goes
I'm a choice the most two important
things in life never writing your
friends and always keep your mouth shut
they're not gonna tell tell the truth
about what the hell is going on right
you feel what I'm talking about and then
when it comes down to all the stuff that
we're finding out from the FBI with
Hillary with collusion and everything
from covet the origins of of the mass
the vax hunter Biden being the big guy
and everything I I you know that saying
you're not supposed to say I told you so
but doesn't it feel like that entire
time I Told You So I was I was I that
woke that people like me people like you
I'm pretty sure timing in the same boat
I knew it I knew it the whole time and I
wanted to be like I told you guys they
were suppressing the story and when
you're asking about what was in the
story The Bat the big guy the basically
his son was his bag man going to get the
money if that didn't affect the election
then what would so it was a bad he was
The Bag Man so good point yeah respect
what if the story would have gone out
yes what was the story meaning here we
go hear me good we've all we've already
established that half the country or you
know a little bit less than half the
country was voting for Trump regardless
yes the other half of the country was
Voting against Trump regardless meaning
like
you know Trump says I could shoot
somebody on Fifth Avenue murder and I
still wouldn't lose a vote meaning
people are dug in got it so this story
leaks Hunter laptop we had the guy John
Paul Mack what is the story okay and
what is the story that would motivate
somebody to change their vote that
they're already locked in on go ahead
okay so so for instance like I brought
up the Hillary and the collusion and the
Russia and she paid a firm uh to to get
all this dirt if we found out because
one of the stories that he was saying
when we spoke to him I spoke to him in
the green room is that Hunter Hunter was
getting sent around the world to do
little shady deals and the big guy his
father the vice president at the time
was getting a cut okay hence one of the
reasons when this covet hit you're
keeping this guy in a basement because
the story is getting hot so nobody could
know and we can't even even dig into the
story to find out what the deal is so
one of the things besides him doing
crack cocaine he's yo he's one of the
luckiest crackheads in the world he
could do crack record it it could go
public and nothing happens to the guy
he's winning in that sense but if we
find out that he's doing all these deals
and he's giving a cut to his father even
as vice president you can't be the
president bro you're doing Shady deals
with China what you create with Russia
with all these people it's Shady
business bro and if if we were mad about
a fake story that Hillary put in about
collusion that's a major story bro
that's why you keep him in the basement
so don't let him talk and this election
was tight you go back and look at
Arizona Georgia Pennsylvania Wisconsin I
don't want to talk about the accusations
of ballots I don't I just want to say
that mathematically the final numbers
whether you believe them or not were
freaking tight very tight in those four
states that was the whole election they
knew every election they knew it was
tight they knew that this was look they
knew when do you remember the two weeks
before the election with Hillary and the
news media tone changed they wouldn't
cover the Trump rally remember how many
people were there you don't have to like
him you don't have to admire him but you
look at who was at the Trump rallies and
you look at how many people weren't at
the Hillary walk rallies something was
going on and they knew it was tight and
with Biden they also knew it was tight
and they also knew they did not have a
compelling candidate and they also knew
that they had made a mistake all the
polling what happened six weeks before
the election count the appearances that
Kamala Harris made six weeks before the
election they stuck her in the basement
with Hunter why because she was not a
compelling vice presidential candidate
they knew this thing was tight they knew
they were on it and on October 20th
October 6 they were like man this is the
Hillary email story this is the Trump
drunk driving story we lose a point and
a half and it wasn't the entrenched as
you correctly point out people were dug
in that's not who it was it was the
American Independent voter that was
right there in the middle and would not
have taken many of them in Arizona
Georgia Pennsylvania Wisconsin and this
thing goes the other way they knew it
was tight they knew they had to suppress
it
do you have a follow-up well you want I
mean listen this is all great this is
amazing I'm not here defending Hunter
Biden I'm not a spokesperson I'm asking
legitimate questions of how much this
actually would have affected the
election you guys seem to be 100 certain
that had this story would have leaked
Trump would be the president right now
and I'm sure many people feel that way
and that's why people are very let me
let me let me do a different thing then
for you let's see if we're going to make
some progress here according to the
definition
of electoral fraud do you somebody who
has a degree
you had a 3.7 GPA in high school
you're a smart guy on paper
do you consider what they did with
Twitter
99 the email exchange which you just saw
based on this definition that we just
Googled that there was election fraud I
believe that they're not in the
traditional sense but in the suppressing
of information yes so according to this
definition because let me read it one
more time I'm gonna read it one more
give me the highlighted part I'm going
to read it one more time because English
is my fifth language so electoral fraud
sometimes referred to as election
manipulation that's manipulation voter
fraud vote rigging involves illegal
interference that's this
with the process of an election either
by increasing the vulture of a favorite
candidate which is this or depressing
the vote share of a rival candidate by
silencing people on Twitter or both okay
so I I hear you out here and I could uh
I just ask one thing was this illegal
because this says illegal interference
was this actually
illegal so so you're thinking what they
did wasn't illegal what just happened
with Twitter wasn't it was it was it in
ethical was it immoral but was it
illegal well it's fraud if it's the
definition of Fraud itself is illegal
okay so let me play guys yeah I believe
I'm playing Devil's Advocate I know you
are you want to just sit around and all
just no
let's be devil's advocate here I'll use
a nice little tone we don't have to be a
double slavish
3.7 GPA the the Benghazi story that they
were doing with Hillary Clinton yeah
Benghazi Benghazi Benghazi Benghazi
Benghazi emails emails emails emails
email emails emails couldn't that be a
very similar situation I don't know why
why don't deflect still not deflecting
but I'm saying stay on this that she's a
criminal and that's validated yeah
people around her commit suicide too
often
that and by the way she's one of the
most feared people in politics not him
people love Bill Clinton they fear her
do I know 100 no but if 74 whatever the
number is if 50 people around you if 10
people around you keep committing
suicides I'm a little bit concerned I
watch this document Henry 400 people
that this nurse was looking at they made
a documentary whatever they called this
guy the movie came out the good nurse
400 people died because they're taking a
drug this guy eventually went to jail
the difference between her is she
controls all these political
organizations so she's not gonna be
going to jail it's not going to happen
to how many people 57 people from
Clinton's Inner Circle have died in a
strange Circumstance the last 30 years
yeah it's a weird number bro yeah I mean
the other day Steph Curry made five
full court shots with one hand did you
see it I thought that was fake I thought
it was fake everybody shocked
with one hand he made five full court
shots this guy's the greatest shooter of
all time when he did this yeah when you
see something like that with Hillary
there's odds are there's something going
out there so going back to this
to say whether it's illegal or not and
beat around the bush with the story what
they did is election fraud that's the
definition of it
and fairness
go for it what's your level of certainty
that she is a murderer my level of
certainty in life works in the following
way I play with odds just like I do in
Investments sure I bought an mbappe card
his most expensive car two months ago
the reason why I bought an mbappe car
two months ago is because I think that
guy's a badass mother you know what and
he's showing you right now and guess
what he just officially tied the messy
and I think one more than Ronaldo or
something like that for the most goals
ever in the world cup by player and he's
only 23 years old those guys are in the
late 30s okay his card that I bought
doubled in price in the last two months
okay that's an odds game okay that I'm
playing investment if I talk to my kids
and last night the five Frescas are
missing and Melva tells me five Frescas
are missing and I'm sitting there
interrogating these kids to see who had
the three Frescas we know we ended up
finding out because of odds based on who
likes Fresca demos and who's an expert
in that area Okay So eventually we got
the Intel I went to my Twitter files in
my house and found out who drank the
most Fresca and the guy eventually
admitted to it who it was okay so it
wasn't Senna but the point with
something like this with Hillary 54
people yeah I mean you're naive if you
think it's a good idea to get into her
Inner Circle you're very nice person if
you think it's a honorable thing to go
work for somebody like that when you see
what happened with Twitter and saying I
don't think it would have made a
difference in election you're either
naive or the following and by the way
this is what I'm about to tell you right
now I'm giving you a bone okay and you
can pick this and play with it all you
want you ready all of us to an extent
have selective hearing
we can only see the good our kids do
great parents understand that their kids
do things wrong and they got to be
disciplined either by their teacher by
their coach or people around them okay
great parents
sometimes we only see good in everybody
sometimes we don't want the story to
come out because we hate Trump so we
don't want to give him any credit for
anything God forbid if this story
validates that Trump should have been
president and I'm wrong today and I
gotta go pay back all the people I took
money from sometimes we don't like that
story right okay
but in reality this is a real story okay
and a lot of people that voted for him
are going back to Walmart asking for
refund right now saying I want my vote
back they're not happy about their vote
but there are those who secretly they're
so proud that they publicly looked so
good when Trump lost they can't give in
to this thing to give it any kind of
credence because God forbid if they do
guess what they were wrong we hate to be
wrong cannot stand buyers remorse but a
lot of people got buyers remorse we can
move on to the next story a little
pushback I love you I respect you you're
my mentor you're my boss you didn't give
me the odds though what are the odds
that she's a murderer oh you're going
into that you didn't answer the question
you told me who found them yes I think
that's a fair answer what are the odds
that she's involved in those 54 people
that committed suicide I don't know bro
I'm in the 60 percentile okay yeah by
the way I appreciate that number because
we learned something when we interviewed
the Philip muds former CI and this is
something that I I constantly constantly
navigate to and I implore the audience
to use this as well there's a major
difference between what you think and
what you know and what you can prove
yeah and nobody's proved that she's done
that well if you're giving 60 no no I'm
saying 60 but let me tell you but
there's people out there that are like
100 bro I know for a fact bro
but 54 people there's a little bit of
smoke
people would follow that closely Adam if
54 of my sales people had committed and
they worked their direct reports of mine
you should reconsider I know who I'm
looking at
isn't it the guy who would be
responsible
I think this is appropriate to go into
two stories I want to go into two stores
I want to go into the Trump story next
then CNN layoffs I think all those are
kind of going together so Trump calls
for a termination on the Constitution
over Elon Musk Twitter files leak huffle
former president Donald Trump suggested
that the contents of the leaked
warranted a complete election reader or
simply a coup in which he would be
installed as president a massive fraud
of this type and magnitude allows for
determination of all rules regulations
and articles even those found in the
Constitution Trump wrote on true social
and a follow-up he added unprecedented
fraud requires unprecedented cure in all
the certainty of late 2020 Twitter went
to relatively extreme lengths to deal
with the laptop Story the platform
blocked it
sharing a link to the New York Post
story meant your accounts could be
blocked until you deleted it which is
what happened to then White House Press
Secretary Kelly
mccanny whatever her name I'm gonna
eventually get it okay she's old news by
the way uh so this story here with
Constitution what are your thoughts on
this what uh Trump said well I'm not so
much worried about where what Trump said
because obviously Trump has a has a
position here and he's sticking to it
I'm more concerned with what Elon musk's
response was did you see Elon musk's
response where he said no president or
no person is bigger than the
Constitution and I think that's
something that we can all get behind no
yeah no I I agree I agree on that here's
here's what I will tell you
think if you're so you have to look at
this from a couple different
perspectives as an American no the
Constitution is the Constitution okay as
an American if everybody agrees on doing
something with the Constitution from
both sides it's something we ought to
entertain could be something we ought to
entertain
um but at the same time
do think about if you're sitting there
saying I'm telling you guys they did
this I'm telling you and you're like nah
you're an idiot you don't know what
you're talking about you're just a
criminal you're the one that's
manipulating this two years later yeah
everything I said they did they did yeah
but you know who cares this two years
ago nobody really cares about its old
story think about how you would feel as
an individual so his understanding is
just frustrated and just going going to
like his anger yeah he's nuts right Adam
but it's validating his anger in January
6. I don't give a [ __ ] what people call
it Insurrection the threat of dog it was
a peaceful meaning hold on hold on hold
on bro if let's be real it was a bunch
of dorky ass people taking photos on
Pelosi's desk people were getting them
let in there was FBI dudes rattling
people up let me explain something bro
if you're more I'm not condoning people
getting killed because I think one one
guy had a stroke or whatever but there's
people are more mad at that than were
this is cheating bro they cheated they
stopped stories who knows what up what
else [ __ ] that they stop I don't give a
[ __ ] well January 6 I don't give a [ __ ]
to be honest you that's why Pat do you
guys think that that now that whole
comedian all that that smoke is gonna
die out now because guess what he's oh
they cheated they they withheld stories
so now it's validating his anger towards
it and I'm sorry here's my question too
do you think of right now they just did
a recal a re-election whatever all right
guys he's out of the basement this story
is out does he want does he win the the
vote does he win the election right now
today if they started all over again no
kovid no everything no no I'm just
saying no no everyone wants to play
Monday Morning Quarterback and go back
two years and figure out what happened
well I know this Donald Trump is a toxic
candidate I also know that Joe Biden is
a very poor candidate and in America
today we have choices between shitty
candidates okay I'm not a team I'm not
on team blue I'm not on team red I'm on
team red white in blue and this is the
reason why everyone and their mother is
like I don't know Ron DeSantis I really
wish I could I I have I have very good
friends I bring this up all the time who
are as maggoted out as they come and
they're texting me and they're saying
hey bro I can't continue to be on the
Trump train so I don't know I mean and
who gives a [ __ ] we're not going back to
2020 as much as Trump truths about it or
tweets about it whatever they call it a
truth she's truth we're not going back
and at the same time I understand why
people feel angry things were censored
you know big Tech has a major role in
disseminating information or limiting
information so there's a lot of a lot of
people have a lot of Bones to pick which
I totally understand and I and I
empathize with those people but at the
same time it's 20 23 in about 25 days
yeah yeah we're not going back to 2020.
I agree it's all I agree move on I agree
and try to clean it up for 2024. by the
way it's we've had two and a half years
to discuss the hunter Biden laptop and
suppressed though how much did that
affect the midterms not much so well
wait a minute wait a minute you can't
say it oh you could it didn't affect the
midterms because this never came out
before the midterm it didn't come up if
this would have come out before the
midterms you're saying it's not going to
impact the midterms you know what's
going to impact the midterms the timing
of this was perfect for the left because
this is going to impact elections zero
it's not going to impact uh midterm and
it's not going to impact 2024. it
couldn't come out at a better time for
the left period
if I'm a strategic Democratic whatever
uh strategist let's just say for the for
the left I'm sitting there saying guys
relax the worst POS the best possible
time for us the worst possible time for
the Republicans this ain't gonna do
nothing this story is going to move on
in the next two months three months
they're done we're gonna move on to the
next thing and we'll find a bunch of
stuff on DeSantis Trump that will make
up and people will buy don't worry about
it okay but let me let me transition
into the story and tell them I want to
get your thoughts on the CNN story
hired extra security after cutting
hundreds of Staff members
uh this is a uh Daily Mail story let me
go to the story here so uh CNN CEO
Chrisley reportedly hired extra security
to stand outside a conference room and
follow him around after cutting Network
staff licked laid off hundreds of
employees including some big name on-air
talents like preet bahara Alison
acoustic Dan America and Chris silsa
Lake had sat in the executive conference
from throughout the day with the doors
open to take questions from remaining
employees about the string of cuts While
most of the cuts were off-camera
employees contributors producers and
reporters like Martin Salvage Marianne
Fox and Alex field also faced layoffs
and also are now forced to look for
employment elsewhere another major
casualty of licks Cuts was CNN spin-off
HLN and its entire step that's why the
lady was crying so what are your
thoughts on this Tom well I think
we are such an angry people right now
that uh a CEO that's brought in to
combination to a turnaround and part of
that he has to wield the hatchet on
staff
um it's not surprising to me and I think
it's very
prudent that he did this but is
completely unsurprising we are such an
angry people right now and you're laying
off a bunch of folks I applaud the fact
that if it is true that he was in the
conference room he was taking questions
so it sounds like he's trying to
communicate it hey there's no good way
to say this we're s we we are not
getting uh good Advertiser response this
was not done out of pettiness this was
not done out of preference this was how
this was done out of a lack of profit
and there's no money to pay these people
so he had to make changes including some
large contracts that apparently people
that weren't pulling viewership so I I
look at it and say you may not like what
it looks like America but this was a
business decision and it and if it is
true I applaud that he at least tried to
have a dialogue with people but the fact
we are so angry and we are so on edge
you know you know he had to get security
and I understand that you know you know
what's interesting about this this
happens every large organization goes
through this but you know what happened
with Twitter when Twitter laid off 37 3
500 people it was cover story everywhere
he's a terrible man but when CNN does it
it's a different story right think about
how they have to spend the way they're
letting people go versus how when
Twitter store every other second they
were talking about Elon Musk let's go 3
500 people Elon Musk let's go 3 500
people and then you're doing this FYI
John Malone
I think you said
you want to go back to journalistic
Integrity you said that okay these are
your words you said you want to take CNN
back to Real by the way is there audio
cut up do you hear my audio
I think you guys are good mind sums
happen with mine if the audio is if the
if the audience is not hearing anything
going on my audio then it's just my mic
it's fine but I hear something going on
with my mic but if John if you're
talking about you really want to do that
to CNN and you're really committed to it
can I ask you why you haven't yet
covered this Twitter story there has to
be conference calls with leaders at the
top or are you like when the stories at
Twitter the story didn't come up to Jack
Dorsey because maybe he wasn't involved
during those times maybe he was off site
and you don't think the Twitter story
needs to be told by your people what do
you think you think the fake news
labeled that CNN got is gradually going
away or you think you're increasing it
by actually not talking about what was
just released this past Saturday by
Twitter documentation not opinions
screenshots of Email exchange there is
nothing more real than an email coming
from a person telling you what they're
asking somebody of an organization like
Twitter to do and you still haven't
covered it so guess what CNN you are
still fake news and until you're willing
to do your part competing on both sides
telling doing journalism on both sides
unfortunately until that changes CNN is
still fake news till today hopefully
they'll do something about it because we
need competition in media I told this
thing about how all of us here use an
iPhone okay does anybody not use an
iPhone Rob tell us you don't use an
iPhone your iPhone this is terrible news
by the way that everybody uses iPhones
we need competition and media so people
are watching everybody we need it
everywhere this doesn't benefit if CNN
is not doing journalism anymore it does
not benefit it so you know when I see a
stat like this one criticism if you
criticize others for getting laid off
and you just did it yourself it's kind
of painful number two if you really say
you want to change turn things around
well maybe you start kind of talking
about some real stuff instead of just
fake fake fake I'm constantly I wonder
about his security were they armed
because I mean people have seen that I'm
probably like not anti-second Amendment
but ain't nobody there got a gun so they
were just a bunch of buff guys walking
around like we got you okay because this
guy um John Malone is who compared to
Chris Licht Chris Licht is a new CEO and
John Maloney's the billionaire yeah
he's the new Ted Turner he's the new
he's the Ted Turner is a Founder but
he's the new guy that owns and runs the
company since um since you're an odds
guy
um what percentage of CNN do you think
of what they disseminate is fake news
uh what percentage what they disseminate
is fake news right because it's not a
hundred percent it's not zero percent so
of of course same thing for Fox and I
mean for everyone of course it's not of
course an odds guy yeah I would I don't
know the exact number I'm not gonna sit
here and tell you it's fake news or it's
not I guess what I would say is more
um
lack of doing your job bias listen for
us we're not journalists you can call
the citizen journalism but opinion we
run businesses for a living we we run
come with this is a podcast we're going
to talk about a bunch of different
business stories today we're gonna have
laughters we're gonna entertain we're
going to educate we're gonna Enlighten
we're going to talk about
entrepreneurship Capital that's what
we're gonna do and we're going to do
this every day that's what we're doing
with our company right
these guys their job is to tell us what
the hell is going on they get paid to do
investigative journalism and we're
getting none of that how many people are
sitting there investigating what's
really going on with Twitter with Hunter
Biden at CNN zero how many people were
investigating what happened with Russia
collusion everybody and ended up being
wrong do you realize how pathetic an
organization looks when they do that
credibility of CNN look at this this is
statista this is not anybody else zoom
in a little bit if you could zoom in a
little bit okay I mean very credible 23
somewhat credible 30 percent not
credible at all 12 percent not at all
credible twenty percent
heard of no opinion 13 never heard about
this I mean I don't know if what's this
Rob scroll in or out scroll and so I go
to the left what's the second number 20
and 30 30 yeah so 50 of the country
thinks that they're very or somewhat
reliable 53 53 47 by the way right and
the other half of the country says that
they're not very credible or not at all
credible which is kind of America it's
kind of America I'd like to see foxes
but you know you know what I would say
again with them if you go and you
investigate Russia and you told us we're
not the experts that that's what
happened and it was all fake you're
criminals
your criminals you cause how many
unnecessary fights that that fake story
about Russia created oh my God how many
families yeah you're absolutely right I
do think that so for instance
um
who was he on the other day was it um oh
is Ari um pleasure Ari Fleischer and he
said I said give me someone who's
credible because this whole thing was
that journalism is very biased and he's
I liked the name he gave and he said
that Brett Bear at the you know five
o'clock six o'clock hour on Fox News
That's someone that he finds me very
credible I actually happen to like Brit
bear I've met Brett Baron person I took
a picture with them and gave him respect
I usually think that's the type of
person but then you know after seven
o'clock eight o'clock then you get into
the lower Ingram and Tucker so there is
a difference in this kind of it's by the
way the same thing with with you know
you have Wolf Blitzer and you have uh
Jake Tapper who I also find to be pretty
credible and then you get into the Don
Le Mans and you get into you know the
Anderson Coopers so there is a major
difference between newsmen newscasters
even journalists to that regard and
opinion journalists and I think that
that's there's like this conflated sense
of like
well it's all kind of it's on CNN so
it's all intertwined or it's all [ __ ]
what's my point is that I think on
certain shows opinion shows there should
be
sort of a disclaimer that this is Don
lemon's opinion I agree this is Tucker
Carlson's opinion versus someone like
Brett Bear or someone like
um Shepard Smith or someone like Jake
Tapper where it's like this is the news
because you can't treat the same equally
just like how you kind of gave us like
listen we're business people we're doing
a podcast here we're not the news we're
not the journalists so there's a do
people understand that this is an
opinion do not agree you asked for Fox's
score here's foxes it was 58 Fox is 58
CNN is 53. okay I'm saying what I can't
see so good no no you you asked for the
question they're very credible and the
somewhat credible foxes 58 CNN was 53.
so fox has got the CNN beat by five
percent so America trusts Fox News more
than they trust CNN by five percent
that's a big percent that's ten percent
more that's and that's not a small
percentage you're talking about when it
comes down to percentages I give them
you know I would I would respect them
more if they just had to whoever's in
charge now just to be like hey guys look
right in the camera I'm like we we
[ __ ] up we're sorry try to be better
what I'm saying is then people might
kind of chip because like you say Adam
it's not objective journalism they're
political activist and I get it I'm
pretty sure the DNC gives money to CNN
right and the Republican Party hooks up
Fox but why is why is the fox winning
why are they killing stuck at Carlson
number one and killing it is it just
that many more Republicans out there
let's move on let's move on to some
business stories here so Tom I'm gonna
go to you first four and ten consumers
expect housing market will crash survey
finds four in ten consumers believe uh
housing market will crash economists and
real estate in this by the way that's a
uh Economist and real estate industry
leaders generally agree that the U.S
housing market has slowed and will
continue to in 2023 but have tended to
use words like temper modest correction
when referring to declining sales and
price ahead crash is a word that has
been almost universally avoided
consumers may have gloomier expectations
a recent Lending Tree survey of 2033
Americans ages 18 to 76 found 41 believe
the housing market will crash in the
next 12 months crash as the find as a
significant drop in home values in a
short period of time of those expecting
to crash three out of four think it will
be as bad as worse of 2008 housing crash
home prices posted the third straight
monthly decline in September Tom
thoughts what's really interesting I dug
into this and there's you say to
yourself well why do people think this
why do they think it and so I back up
and say what are they thinking and I
looked in here and right now the days
that listings are on is is is extending
I saw Redfin I saw Zillow stats so the
number of days are on the market are
getting longer and longer and longer and
the number of showings is is is like way
off and it's because interest rates are
high people can't afford to buy houses
so if Vinnie's selling his house
Vinnie's my friend I said how's it going
it's going nowhere man I had a good
realtor it's been on the market nobody
came here open house was like three
couples and you know it's just sitting
it's just sitting there we he and she
told me to drop at forty nine thousand
dollars so I dropped it forty nine
thousand dollars and it's still sitting
so Americans number one they know that
things are sitting on the market number
two they know that the mortgage rates
are higher and it's making them all
worried those are the two facts that you
get you dive into the consumer sentiment
that's what they say man nobody can sell
a house in our in our street and boy
look at the mortgage rates the average
person that doesn't read The Wall Street
Journal who's just aware of their own
Community that's what they're seeing
what's also interesting is how Regional
this is right now California Washington
Oregon and Nevada it is in crash mode
whereas South Florida buoyed by a huge
influx of people called demand the
market has only moved about three four
percent so depending on where you live
is also connected to this but consumers
are not dumb and they're they're seeing
what's out there and suddenly it feels
pretty bleak and you survive survey them
and they said oh this thing's gonna
crash
top let me ask rational confusion in
your expert opinion we can all agree
that the 2008 financial crisis were
spurned by the mortgage-backed
Securities and the what was the Nina no
income no assets and basically the loose
lending right I mean that's
essentially the reason that the economy
almost tumbled all these mortgage-backed
Securities and all this uh loose
underwriting so yeah yeah they we were
default and inventory so there was a lot
of Bad actors there was a lot of you
know loose underwriting there was
whether it was a legal fraudulent you
know I don't know how many people went
to jail for it I don't know but people
were sort of calling it Michael burry so
there were some definite reasons for
that in your expert opinion what are the
the one or two bullet point reasons why
this crash would happen now is it
interest rates is it is it supply and
demand what would it be well first of
all what goes up must come down and
because we printed all that money we
artificially inflated asset prices we've
talked about this on the podcast but
before from cards sports cards
collectors to
artworks used cars popped up remember
and so what goes up must come down and
right now what you've got is this crash
is not going to be the structural
disaster where you had all of those
um adjustees popped because remember
what happened wasn't that they had bad
loans it's that they all adjusted and
once the adjustment started it was this
horrible downhill
storm of people defaulting because the
interest rate came up and they're like
sorry I can't pay that I have to default
what you have right now is you had
artificially inflated prices that have
to come back down and they're coming
back down in the face of two things
interest rates are really high and you
you've got you know the affordability in
terms of the individual consumers so the
demand side so I don't see a structural
disaster the way there was with the
adjustable mortgages that suddenly
adjusted and squeezed everybody and they
defaulted I do see that the prices were
artificially inflated and now you've got
oh interesting the areas that have low
demand like California Washington where
people are moving out of those blue
States reducing the demand for houses
and that's where you see it coming down
first but Americans are not dumb uh
they're out there right now and they're
they're feeling this and for a lot of
people average means this is sad let me
go to this next one because there's
different markers when you look at this
fewer tourists and less spending in Las
Vegas as inflation takes this toll
inflation has taken its toll on sin city
as fewer tours are visiting the gambling
Mecca and those who do spend less than
usual the University of the Las Vegas
business school released the report
forecasting the city's economic Outlook
between 2022 and 2024 noted that its
economic turn Grim in June of this year
interest rates have gone up and we know
that we know the prices are going up as
well and that's what the FED is trying
to get their hands around and solve so
it may be that feds policies is having
an effect not only nationally but it's
also affecting our economy locally one
of the studies authors Professor Stephen
Miller said Tom
you know what's interesting about this
as well
um basically people in Las Vegas are
hurting because you know you can spin
everything you want in the news and
we've just covered that a little bit but
there are two things that are very very
true right now savings rates are
crashing and people have stuff on
um credit cards and they're using that
for average purchases if you're doing
that you do not have that extra 500
bucks to go with two buddies to go see a
ball game in Vegas and gamble a little
bit you just don't have it and
that is the core of Vegas
and you're you're seeing it right now
and so the tourism's down and when the
tourists are there we don't spend as
much we gamble a little bit not a lot of
bit we don't party we don't have a four
thousand dollar bachelor party for our
buddy it's we spend less or we don't go
that's crazy when you're saying that
when when covet happened I would go to
Vegas regularly because we were signing
a contract with MGM granddarino so that
my driver would pick me up and I would
say so tell me how I would ask everybody
how's traffic in Vegas not bad kid how
is it oh everyone got laid off MGM how
many people got laid off here 90 of our
people working for MGM Grand Arena laid
off no way what are they doing they're
all trying to find some work but where
did they have to move out because you're
in the event business right you can so a
way to gauge economy is Las Vegas a wage
to gauge economy is nightclubs a way to
gauge like the story you were talking
about yesterday with Miami
11 has six million dollars of Bitcoin
they accept it to this year 11 000 in
the last 90 days that's just
mind-boggling to me when you hear a
number like that right so nightclubs
tells a story Las Vegas tells a story
gambling tells a story all of these
things are telling a story you know now
somebody may come back and say well Pat
didn't we have record-breaking Black
Friday and Cyber Monday that's also a
story because the numbers were up for
online sales but the numbers were down
for physical going to a place which
makes sense people no longer want to go
to a physical Place deal with lines
standing outside dude I just go on
Amazon and buy it and it's going to be
shipped to me anyways and nowadays
they're shipping faster so this you know
I was so disappointed Thanksgiving day I
usually like to watch the riots at Best
Buy where people come in 70 inch TV they
took the year off and and uh but I mean
think about it if it's that's the
biggest sale day people are going to
spend money that they you know they get
Kinder because it's 40 off but Tom what
do you think would be what's going to be
like this crash that they're talking
about and I know since I've been here
I've been here for six months you guys
have kind of been you know where I'll
bring around you know 6 12 18 32 you
know whatever what do you think is gonna
be be that breaking point where it's
just gonna like I'm not hoping for the
2008 crash but like people like me that
have been kind of saving and stuff
because listening to my boy Adam like
we're wanting to buy Pat I want to I'm
gonna probably live in Florida for the
rest of my life I want to buy a house
I'm not going to take advantage of
people's failures but I'm waiting when
you think I know we've been talking
about it what's going to be the the the
straw to break the camel's back I'll
defer back to Papa we've been talking on
this podcast for a while that the that
Goldman and others are calling top rate
was it pat five and a quarter four uh
three quarters like May right that's
what they're calling top they believe
that's gonna be the top now what that
means Vinnie is that's when the
increases stop because they believe they
have inflation under control based on a
lot of things they watch including
unemployment once that happens and it
comes down then you're gonna see you
know so maybe housing opportunities out
there and you're not taking advantage of
somebody's Misfortune if they have to
sell that cows and you have the
capability buying that house that is a
transaction it may not be as good as
those people like it but you know let me
give you a data let me I'm sorry I just
want to give one thing about Vegas
yeah well that's true uh I think we can
all agree you're not going to Vegas like
you're going to Florence to go check out
the uh history you're going there to
party to drink to gamble to do sinful
type of activities that's why it's
called Sin City so I'll give you a story
two years ago a buddy of mine was having
his bachelor party and most of us live
in in South Florida and Miami and he's
like dude we're gonna go to Vegas it's a
very emotional decision to go party and
live it up but that's it's not like
logical acting well you know I think we
should have a good time let's go we're
gonna party we're gonna rage I said guys
let me give you a little food for
thought
there's 10 guys
okay I said we're all gonna fly to Vegas
we all gotta get hotel rooms we all
gotta you know eat meals this that party
clubs nonsense gamble I said we're all
gonna end up spending three grand a
person okay that's 30 freaking Grand
between 10 dudes I said if we just stay
in Miami don't succumb to our emotional
you know private instincts what do you
think we could do with 30 grand staying
here in Miami yeah and I wrote it down I
said we could do this this this this
this
universally unanimously they're like
atom logical reason we are staying in
Miami by the way for 10 grand we had a
ridiculous bachelor party I would have
invested the rest of the 20. what I'm
saying stay local and save that money
that's a great story dude that's dope so
I'll see you at the comedy club make it
rain this the question you just asked
let's address the question you just
asked when is a good time to buy a house
right because a lot of people I was on
Tom ferries podcast and we were going
back and forth he had another guy that's
a real estate expert well I don't think
I think maybe the real estate is going
to take a hit or on you know somewhere
shy of five percent next year in 2023
speaking like a realtor sweetheart of a
guy but that's what they're saying right
now okay savings rate plunges to lowest
since 2005. this is an axial story
Americans are spending most of what
they're earning these days okay the
savings rate in October was the lowest
since 2005. and the second lowest on the
record ever let me say that one more
time folks it's very important Vinnie
for you to hear this I am Americans are
spending most of what they're earning
these days do you know how scary that is
the savings rate in October was the
lowest in two since 2005 and the second
lowest on record ever this is America
richest country in the world ever right
thanks to higher prices and a return to
normal life that has folks traveling and
going out again Americans are spending
more than saving less and for now many
are sitting on a lot of savings so that
they don't need to suck as much money
away
keyword they're sitting on a lot of
savings right now a lot of folks build
up a big cash cushion over the past
couple years but the inflation trending
higher than wage increases at some point
some things got to give so what does
this mean all right so people are not
selling a house right now for what it
should be worth because they have some
money they're not in a hurry uh people
are I bought a tiger what's most
expensive best card I just bought it
sold for 396 000 a year and a half ago I
just bought it for 140 000 cash and he
wanted 300 and I paid 144. this card
sold
17 months ago for 396 I bought it 440
000 okay I just bought a Joe burrow car
that's a million dollar card it's one of
one it's a national treasure one of one
I bought the car for three hundred
thousand dollars wow okay I bought a
couple mbappe cards Max's last name
what's Max's last name the driver that
won two Formula One championships uh
first happened first happened I just
bought two of his cars that guy's a
freaking set of a guy right young too
and and buying I just bought the patron
second best card I think that guy's the
start of a guy that's a million and two
card I bought it for four hundred
thousand dollars 380 000 right so people
are starting to sell things like that so
cash is still available to people
they're being Reckless not saying not
saving money thinking that money is
going to be coming regularly they have
no clue what happens when unemployment
goes up high next year and then
eventually in the next six nine 12
months they're going to sit there and
say babe I think we have to be realistic
that conversation with a realtor is
going to be had and the realtor is going
to sit in there and say listen John Mary
I have to tell you guys this if you're
not going to hear from me you can hear
from the next realtor if you fire me and
here's what the conversation is and she
he's going to show he or she's going to
show five six seven different stories
it's going to say real estate's taking a
hit and although you think this is a
million dollar home this is actually 790
000 home at best I say we go on the
market with 870 and if we get offers in
a high sevens let's entertain it and
that Realtor has to sit there just like
a doctor telling a patient if you don't
stop losing weight and stop eating
sweets you're going to have a heart
attack and die in the next 12 to 24
months doctors have to have that
conversation then it's on the patient to
say what Doc is full of [ __ ] what are
you talking about no problem keep eating
what you're eating two years later I'll
see you again for a heart attack and
we'll have that meeting as a matter of
fact set it up in the calendar because
your lifestyle is leading to a heart
attack yeah people are starting to
realize their financial situation is
about to have a heart attack and
unfortunately very few of us
like to pay attention to different
markers that's training trending towards
a bad event coming up in our personal
life in our finances and our health in
many different aspects of Our Lives
arrogance we we are so blind we have so
many blind spots Human Nature has that
right America is going through it so if
I'm again I'm not an expert in this
space I'm not going to sit here and tell
you I'm a real Aesthetics we can talk to
some other people about that my opinion
is if I'm buying something I'm very
patiently waiting until middle of next
year to Q3 of next year okay if I'm
going to be living in a house for 10
years fine go buy a house today but if
I'm looking at something that I'm buying
that I don't know if I'm going to live
in it for 10 years I'm probably waiting
till middle of next year Adam
look
um I love the fact that when it comes to
your money it's called personal finance
because if there's anything that that
I'm an advocate of and I know we're all
Advocates of it's personal
responsibility and personal decisions we
live in freaking America for those of us
that live in America what a blessing to
be able to live here and not deal with
the nonsense that the rest of the world
has to deal with and you know one of the
things I always say is there a
difference between broke and poor poor
is man you're living in a poor ass
country you have no opportunities that
you are poor you know poor is a is a
horrible mindset is a horrible situation
to be with broke is a different thing
broke as you make 50 Grand a year and
somehow you can't get by on on 50 Grand
a year broke is I make 100 Grand a year
and somehow I'm living paycheck to
paycheck you see these stats of these
Millennials fifty percent of Millennials
making 100 Grand or more are living
paycheck to paycheck
you see these stories and it's like on
one hand I'm like hey I hear you I
understand it's tough out there but on
the other hand I'm like buddy you're
making 100 Grand a year figure it though
out yeah so everything comes down to
wants versus needs understanding keeping
up with the Joneses understanding what
lifestyle creep is the more money you
make the more money you want to spend on
nicer things and um at the end of the
day you have the power to control your
own finances you have the power to go
get another job you have the power to
stay home on a Saturday night versus
going to Vegas like we just discussed so
at the end of the day save that money
it's on you I think Pat well I didn't
want to put it out on blast here I think
because Pat what we're a point we're
getting to me and Adam would like to
borrow 500 Grand from you and 500 Grand
from you and start an app called Vegas
we've discussed these stories that have
kind of gone up and down like a yo-yo
over the last couple years with kovid
you know they're using like the return
to normal which is like go back out and
just spend money and versus we've seen
debt come down and then personal savings
go back up and house prices but the end
of the day it's it's your own individual
decisions what you do with your money
and your finances is it not it is and
and you gotta for some people right now
they're going through really rough times
it's for some people to really
experience into pain you know like think
about going to sleep every night
worried about your company is about to
announce layoffs and if you're on that
list and you have to clean up your
resume okay that's a scary place to be
but I will also remind those same people
if it's a scary place today listen if we
can just be straight up with you you
were very arrogant a year and a half ago
bullying your employer for constant
raises every 90 days and threaten them
to leave if they didn't give you a raise
you know who you are if you're listening
to this you did that so both ways if you
did that you're paying a price today
because a a jeded I asked me a question
she says
does a a body count matter okay do you
remember when Janet asked me the
question does body count matter yeah and
I said here's the best way for me to
explain body count like do you if a
girl's been with 100 guys or 50 guys or
whatever does that really matter I said
the same way it matters if you have 20
jobs in the last 10 years on your resume
okay if you got 20 jobs on your resume
the last 10 years that tells me you
don't know how to handle conflict you
eventually quit you're the problem it's
not the company it's not the
organization you're a part of you're you
have a negative attitude you probably
also get other people to quit you
attract the life out of the place you
blame everybody there's an issue with
you going into 2024 that's got 2023
that's got to change so if the trends by
the way if somebody's listening to this
we can all sell others and blame
everybody for our problems we can blame
our bosses we can blame everybody or we
can sit there and say no this is me dude
in the last 10 years you've had 20 jobs
why is
we got to fix something there right so
as much as some of the people that are
going through challenging times right
now you got to go back and look at the
decision making being made a year two
years three years four years five years
ago our current life is a byproduct of
five decisions we made in the last five
years
let me just simplify it for you your
current life today is a byproduct of
five decisions you made in the last five
to ten years who you married what you
bought job you took why you quit how you
lost your emotions in a situation that
you could have stayed calm it's really
five decisions you made you take those
five decisions out you're probably in a
different financial situation today okay
and if your life is incredible today you
take those five good decisions you made
the last five years your life could be
shitty today so we have to get better at
our decision making process the better
we get at making decisions
life tends to give you better life
better lifestyle better friends better
people better Investments better
opportunities things get better so maybe
if there's one skill set that we need to
improve in 2023 is a system for making
better decisions okay and I I gotta just
give you a shout out for how on point
and accurate that is uh that this is
comes down to individual decisions
individual responsibility it's so on
point with what you said the five
decisions that you've made over the last
would you say five years or whatever ten
years
everyone wants to play the blame game
I'm thinking of a press of a friend he's
like oh you know they don't pay me
enough oh they don't appreciate me and
I'm thinking I know this person I'm like
I see the decisions you're making my
friend I see what you're doing on the
weekends I see you've told me what you
did a few years ago and so I'm I'm able
to be your friend and hear you out but I
also know deep down you weren't making
the best decisions yeah so you want to
kind of blame the boss or you want to
kind of blame the company or you want to
blame whoever was you know it was your
roommate whatever it was but the hardest
thing to do bro is look in the mirror
and be like
I really could have done better I
shouldn't have done that yeah and that's
hard to do and that's why such so agree
with what Pat is saying by the way we
all have a hard time with that anybody
says they don't they're full of [ __ ]
everybody has a hard time with that but
it's funny you know there's a few things
like last night's meeting Tom was an
awesome meeting I mean one of the
breakthroughs we had last night was
freaking sick it was an emotional
breakthrough we had last night right
absolutely we're going back and forth
back now boom thing it hit right it's
exciting looking at the stuff that we're
working on for 20. you know this whole
week is about business plans I got
meeting after meeting after meeting
after meeting this week I'm going from
you know this visit we have a board
meeting we have an Fab meeting we have a
carrier meeting where we're entertaining
all our top multi-billion dollar
carriers that are flying in town we're
going to be entertaining them we're
going to be telling what we're going to
be doing in 2023. we got this December
for me is a very very busy month mine is
Christmas and by the way
speaking of business plans here we go
I'd like to thank our sponsor which is
the business planning workshop that
you're doing next up Friday which is is
it sold out already Kai will thank you
for this are you better Kai will thank
you for this is it sold out I don't
think it's I think that the live ones is
sold out okay but is it too late to
register no you can at this point
because that thing is sick put the link
below for that wedding Workshop right
here I'd like to thank our sponsor
ourselves for sponsoring this what a
great we did this last year I want to
say we did it in early January massive
hit no this was a massive hit last year
yeah exactly and we're doing again this
December the the the response the
reviews were amazing and if you're if
you're working on a business I mean you
want to kind of give a plug of why they
should attend something like this listen
for the longest time I you know I treat
a business plans like homework until I
figured out what's the right business
plan to write that produces emotions the
average person doesn't look at their
business plan after the month of
February they just don't they just kind
of sit there and say hey it was like a
homework New Year resolution and they're
done with this one we're going to give
you specific 12 building blocks to write
a business plan that increases chances
of the things you write down on your
business plan for 80 percent of them to
become a reality and we're doing this on
December 16th Rob if you can put the
link below for people to get registered
those who want to we'll give you the
link okay next story I want to get into
uh do we want to do musk do we want to
do Kanye do we want to do economy why
don't we finish up this fed the rates
here Tom and the uh economy with Wall
Street Journal I'm gonna go to this one
here so fed to weigh higher interest
rates next year while slowing Rises this
month Federal Reserve officials have a
signaled plans to raise their Benchmark
interest rates by half a point uh at
their meeting next week but elevated
wage pressures could lead them to
continue lifting to higher levels than
investors currently expect that's a
scary thought right there yesterday the
market responded to that data I think it
dropped like a couple percent yesterday
doubt it most officials on September
penciled in Rising rates in between four
and a half to five percent next year
that Landing Zone could rise between
4.75 and 5 and a quarter in the new
projections Fed chair Jerome Powell
outlined two possible strategies for
proceeding one would be to quickly raise
the FED funds rate well above five
percent level broadly anticipate in
financial markets and then lower it
right away
if it turns out they have gone too far
another would be to go slower and feel
your weight a little bit to what we
think is the right level and then to
hold on longer at a higher level and not
lose some policy too early Tom if I'm
reading this correctly am I am I
understanding that this guy is maybe
hinting in January doing three quarters
of basis point maybe up to a point
to just put a big shocker to the system
and see how it responds yeah what we're
seeing is a episode of Dexter playing
out in the economy oh wow the economy is
tied with duct tape to a chair while
Dexter looks in do I do half a percent
with this tool or do I just take the
bone saw and cut off your arm on this
side and that's that's really morbid and
I'm not trying to be funny with that but
when I hear the FED talking like that
well maybe I do three quarters of a
percent in
um you know in the middle of December or
maybe I do a half a percent in January
honey does that mean you get laid off in
December versus January I'm trying to
figure that out Marge you know it's like
it's like this going back and forth but
that's what he's saying what he's saying
is we got some indicators here that said
that inflation is still a problem and
he's trying to decide whether he does a
big increase yell loud at the economy to
see if your kids stop and go to their
rooms and go to bed or if you just raise
your voice a little bit raise it a half
a percent he's TR that's what when you
think about it that's what he's actually
trying to do he's trying to see if he
can get the economy to slow down a
little bit and does he do a big right
now or do a little bit in January but it
doesn't change what we were just talking
about that May June time frame is going
to be the high point now the question is
just is it going to be all the way to
five and a quarter or could we get lucky
and be four and a half ladies and
gentlemen both numbers are big and it's
not going to be a soft Landing if you're
saving your money if you're being
prudent the things we're just talking
about planning for next year your future
will look right great metaphor Tom
Dexter amazing I'm a little nervous now
being around Tom I'm sitting next to him
you would be the per you'd be the
perfect candidate to nice good family
man Christian man Biz doc this Alter Ego
low-key where's Tom going he's got all
these business meetings the funny thing
is if like in his jacket he opens it up
there's like there's a stain of blood
like oh my God
would you
it's red in there
what kind of doctor are you we're
learning a lot yeah
how about we do one last one on the
economy this one's a little bit of an
uplifting story and then we'll go back
to it rubini warns the mother of all
economic crisis Looms
it's just looking at the explicit debts
the figures are staggering Global total
private and public sector debt as a
share of GDP Rose this is insane Tom
from 200 in 1999 to 350 in 2021 the
ratio is now
420 across advanced economies and 330 in
China in the United States it is 420
Which is higher than during the Great
Depression I have to read this to you
one more time I don't know if you kind
of were distracted put your phone aside
and just listen to this for a second I'm
I'm asking you to listen to this for a
second I'm gonna read the sentence just
looking at explicit debts how much debt
we have the figures are staggering
globally total private sector and public
sector debt as a share of GDP Rose from
200 in 1999 to 350 in 2021 the ratio
today is 420 across advanced economies
that's 330 in China but U.S is at 420
Which is higher than during the Great
Depression and after World War II damn
of course that can boost economic
activity if borrowers invest in New
Capital Machinery homes public
infrastructure that deals returns higher
than the cost of Baron but much
borrowing goes simply to finance
consumption spending of above one's
income on a persistent basis and that is
a recipe of bankruptcy more of an
investment in capital can also be risky
whether the borrowers or household
buying a home at an artificially
inflated price a corporation seeking to
expand too quickly regardless of returns
or government that is spending the money
on white elephants extravagant but
useless infrastructure projects hence
the buildback better or other items that
they're doing the inflation reduction
whatever it was called the reduction I
react with governments unwilling to
raise taxes or cut spending to reduce
their deficits Central Bank deficit
monetization will once again be seen as
the path of least resistance but you
cannot fool all the people all the time
okay when you hear this here this guy's
saying this Tom first thing you're
thinking about is what what I'm thinking
about is so put it in perspective
420 percent that means we owe ourselves
four times our annual pay if you want to
think of it that way as a nation and as
interest rates go up we got to pay the
the interest on that which is what makes
that debt be a bigger and bigger percent
of what we have to pay every year and
there's less for positive programs and
like Highway infrastructure so that
Rusty bridges in Wisconsin don't
collapse remember that and those people
ended up in the in the river so
basically you know if we think personal
debt is bad that's nothing compared to
all of us
can we just give a shout out to uh the
writer of this article yeah Tyler Durden
from Fight Club is the author of this
article right now this is Zero Hedge and
he uses I know zero he uses the Tyler
yes of course but you know this
Tyler Durden destructive doomsday or we
all know that but you know I asked you a
question earlier Tom about like the the
reasons why we think the housing market
would crash and you know the the
correlation with what happened in 2008
but for years and years and years we've
been we've been hearing about this
potential debt crisis and this obsession
with debt whether it's in personal debt
whether it's business debt whether it's
gdps countries borrowing debt African
nations going into debt to China debt
debt debt debt Iran borrowed how much
money from China
but this obsession with debt it's not
going to have a good ending for a lot of
people I mean I'll tap into my inner
Dave Ramsey here but Dad is dumb and
unless you can kind of you know what
they what they highlight here unless you
can kind of borrow money and then
parlay that into a higher rate of return
yeah you can obviously grow your wealth
and grow your country's GDP but the
downside to it which is article
highlights it could get very very ugly
and middle what Pat red it says but
borrowing that goes simply to finance
consumption Oh you mean like 1 4 1.4
trillion dollars that was just handed to
people that went to Vegas and bought
things yeah yep so exactly anyway so so
all in all Vinnie in other words you
know the economy is still got some work
to do until it recovers back to normalcy
that's not going to happen for a minute
uh let's talk about the reaction that
they had when uh uh an MSNBC crew if you
can pull up this video so they're
sitting there if you can zoom it in like
yeah there you go so they're talking
about an announcement that DeSantis
makes the person of the year shortlist
you need to see the reaction of what
they say when that is announced check
this out
22 winds down we are beginning to
reflect on the year that was that
includes the highly anticipated
revealing of times annual Person of the
Year Ron DeSantis makes no sense to me
explain these questions but
[Music]
his presence on the list is because he
won re-election in a massive land side
he flipped Miami-Dade and much to the
Chagrin of a prominent former
constituent is uh on the cusp of really
being the front runner for the
Republican nomination so zielinski is
about is on the cusp of winning the
largest land war in Europe uh against
the country 10 times its size that's
that's the victory that he has at his
side so Roger Sanders won Miami-Dade
County so those are kind of like the
parallel in terms of influence those are
the kind of things we're really talking
about it's it's a challenge Miami-Dade I
don't want to dismiss Miami
winning world war three this is my
seventh year leading uh person of the
year and I'll say we do a lot of apples
and oranges comparisons I was gonna say
that's like that's more like apples and
watermelons
by the way can we back up and show who
was on that short list
is that scrolling right there
are you kidding scrolling on that Robert
I mean I'm sorry Malik uh you got the
FED is that what that looks like or the
Supreme Court you've got Elon Musk
you've got Liz Cheney you've got
zelinski Mackenzie Scott Kenzie Scott
who's giving away all her money you got
protests in Iran in Iran on protesters
then who are the who are on the right
safety Advocates and Janet Yellen gun
safety how can you be plural in a in a
person of the year by the way does
anybody want to give their top one or
two of who you would vote for here for
person of the year I mean they've boiled
it down to 10 people DeSantis is on the
short list I think rightfully so who
would be your two pick two off that list
that you think objectively here's the
difference though I think the question
is more
who do you think deserves to be there
and who do you think time's gonna pick
because I'll give you my who I think
time's gonna pick I think you know
zielinski is the the one time's gonna
pick because of the way yeah you know
but so okay go ahead so based on that
who do you think is going to be the
topic he's certainly in the front
running here I don't think Liz Cheney
has a chance I don't think uh I I don't
think Janet Yellen has a chance I don't
think that Mackenzie Scott has a chance
what was the one on the left is that the
Iran protest protesters I would that I
put that up I think on a soft spot in my
head in my heart I think that's that's
something near and dear to what we talk
about here I don't think they're gonna
win uh although did you see what the um
the uh Supreme leaders of Iran are doing
these days maybe we get to that they
might be cutting off the hijab but I
think the Front Runners here are clearly
Elon Musk and zielinski and God forbid
of XI Jing Penguins as well I'd be so
Un-American and Pat I forgot to I forgot
to uh bring this up earlier like it's
kind of weird because the whole I mean
Elon Musk amazed amazing Free Speech
it's killing it I always Adam The
Devil's Advocate I think we talked about
it yesterday I was reading all this pen
he's giving all these people all this
thing and then all of a sudden I started
hearing about the the neural link
they're about to start testing it in
human beings it's almost as if he's
being this it's like almost it could be
if you want to think like like Devil's
Advocate or wolf in sheep's clothing now
all of a sudden people are gonna go hey
this is the free speech he did that now
he wants to sew microchips in our head
I'm in that's gonna be a great selling
point to people that are kind of
skeptical because Pat it's happening
like they're gonna test I think six
human beings really really shortly and I
don't listen I don't trust anything with
microchips and [ __ ] in the body I'm a
Christian I've read the Bible when they
talk about the mark of the beast it's
getting he might be such a pat he might
be that guy and then it's going to make
people's decision to put these things in
there are you saying elon's the guy
that's going to be on the top of the
list is that what you're saying he's
gonna probably be up there 100 so Tom
who's who's your name so I'll tell you I
agree I think Time Magazine is going to
make it zelenski but I'll tell you who I
honestly believe the person of the year
is
um many years ago I was really stirred
when I saw the picture of these people
after they voted remember they would get
the purple dye on their finger because
they had to put them they would hold
their fingers up in the city Square
defiantly saying I voted which was
equivalent to saying hey come Bonk me on
the head right because it was yeah a lot
of or just cut my head off I actually
believe that the person a year in terms
of the people on that list zelenski you
know I see that but the protesters are
around they're risking everything
they're risking everything and
um all for freedom and a little bit of a
better way and thing you know and uh in
terms of raw impact it's Elon Musk but
the protesters around what they are
putting they're putting their necks out
there for a massive greater good that
they may never see it may be their next
Generation True by the way Pat you have
a you have a vote yeah I I so if you
look at this I don't know why G is on
the list okay but I I get it you know
he's a name that's got to be on that
list every single time fine notice who's
not on the list Biden's not on the list
kamala's not on the list Obama's not on
any of those guys are not on this which
fine that makes sense okay
um
if you if you look at it from
advancement and controversy and freedom
of speech musk has only been at it for
six weeks so person of the year I don't
know yet I think it's second or third
what the scientists did he had a
Playbook that showed you you know why
it's so
patriotic for what Ron DeSantis did this
is the part we have to respect about
what this guy did it's very hard to have
convictions
where you lead with those convictions
with the risk of you may be very wrong
and it could be catastrophic but you
believe in your bones you're making the
right decision with kids with schooling
with businesses with covid with all of
that and you end up being right I don't
I don't know because what zielinski is
doing 90 of the world is support not 90
most of the world that support every
channel you turn on he's a hero he's a
hero he's a modern-day Wilson Churchill
every channel mainstream media you turn
on Ron DeSantis is a bad guy so for him
to be right where the NBA held the
playoffs in his state
where Disney World kept doing business
in his State and this land was shut down
where people were going on vacation for
Christmas in his State last year
everybody from La New York Chicago they
were going to Florida for vacation
listen if you truly want to call it
leader of the year
when you leave it person of the year
doesn't necessarily have to be the
leader of the year but if that person of
the year was a leader of the year it's
nobody but Ron DeSantis on that list
it's not by the way and it's not even
close to me yeah you go back it's not
even close he's not having a lucky year
go back and look at the last three years
by the way do you want to consider this
food for thought you want to see Trump
have a meltdown of Epic Proportions if
you want to talk about meltdown go ahead
Time Magazine select Ron DeSantis as the
Time person of the year Ron
sanctimonious whatever Trump calls him
these days these sanctimonious Trump
would have a literal meltdown why does
he deserve because that's we're heading
towards that point don't you agree that
that DeSantis and and Trump are going to
clash at the RNC and we're going to see
what happens but isn't isn't time
predominantly a left-leaning
organization time Big Time by Mark
benihoff okay then guess what Pat what
we want different story zielinski is
going to win because how many any
billions have they got on the duty
they've set this guy up can I ask why
Mackenzie Scott is in the top 10 list
she's giving away billions of dollars so
she's giving away the money that Bezos
made and that's on the list
and gentlemen no you know I think though
Pat because she hooked up with just an
average Joe yeah good person Pat I think
you need to normalize it as a percent
and have a different contest Mackenzie
Scott has only given away 33 of the
money from her husband there are women
in this country that have given away 300
of the money their husbands have
generated yeah very true by the way
she's a rookie we're gonna find this out
in the next couple weeks will they
select this I I think so uh we'll we'll
I'm sure we'll see here so final vote
who are you guys voting just so we can
put a button who's going to who's going
to win okay now odds are on zelinsky
who's gonna who's gonna win zielinski
who I would I would hope which I know
they're not are the protesters in Iran
but I think Elon Musk would be second
place in zelinski is going to win it I
think David
Elon Musk
but protesters in Iran they would have
to have master I mean like they would
have to link it yeah yeah I just can't
believe that really pisses me off don't
underplay the vindictiveness of what
Time Magazine will do just to see
Trump's response we'll see okay by the
way do we want to do so a couple stories
we got left here with the last 10
minutes do we want to do Alex Jones do
we want to do Michael avenatti do we
want to do Kanye West and Elon Musk What
story did we want yeah okay so let's go
to that page five okay
so Elon musk's response to Connie what's
calling him a half Chinese and generic
genetic hybrid a West who was banned
from Twitter for posting a Nazi symbol
last week branded musk a genetic hybrid
and suggesting that he's a half Chinese
on Instagram on Sunday in a bizarre
rambling post the disgraced star also
took him as former president Barack
Obama referring to an outrageous
conspiracy theory that he is a cologne
of an Egyptian pharaoh I take that as a
compliment musk replied West shared a
screenshot of musk response and claimed
his comments had always been intended to
be complimentary West posted a defensive
tweet on Thursday night then posted a
photo of the topless musk on a yacht
writing let's always remember this is as
my final tweet musk responded to the
image of himself saying that is fine but
replied this is not to West's swastika
tweet so go ahead Adam since you had
some thoughts on this well I mean
we we often consider uh Elon Musk to be
a troll right I mean he's he's very good
at it
um but the way that he was able to take
The High Ground here with Kanye I think
he said this wasn't a very flattering
picture of me and it kind of motivated
me to lose weight yeah right did you did
you see that part yeah so it's crazy
because if you if let's actually go to
the source here Google young Elon Musk
Chinese let's look at the picture right
let's let the story speak for itself so
let's find a good nice picture of a
young Elon Musk and see no not
fabricated where they make him look like
Kim Jong-un not a deep fake let's go to
a young Elon Musk and see if he actually
in fact looks Chinese which you know I
mean you know spoiler alert no he's not
Chinese he's a white guy I actually
tried to sell my mom on this like no he
looks shiny she's like what are you
talking about yeah so the comedian John
Mulaney gave it and actually a very
a funny uh take on a bit about this
years ago he said that basically when he
was young people said that he kind of
looked Chinese familiar with this bit
well to what Melanie did Melanie I got
it I might have gone he basically says
when I was young I had this like silky
hair and I had these kind of by the way
John Mulaney is a complete white guy
yeah and he says that all the kids in
school would make fun of him and call
him a China man and he basically says of
all the epithets and the racial epithets
that's just the easiest One China and
man boom and to the it got to the point
here there's John Mulaney looked I guess
Asian in this picture yeah but right
correct just like Elon but he basically
said it got to the point where like he
said nobody is meaner than an eighth
grade boy because they will tell you
like the truth and say the meanest
things about you and
it got to the point where the bullying
was so bad that he uh during a music
appreciation class every time that they
hit the gong everyone in unison would
get up and bow towards him but it just
kind of it just it kind of goes to the
point where it's like clearly this is
not true wow clear this is absurd and to
a deeper level Kanye sing a lot of
absurd crazy ridiculous things and
there's a good percentage of our country
that are like let Kanye talk he's right
he's got some points it's like at what
point can we just recognize that he's
got some serious mental issues going on
right now I think I think we I think the
I mean the majority of us do and it's
just crazy I think we talked about it
Adam we might have I don't remember if
it was you or not but the fact that
obviously he's going through like a
mental situation and he I don't think he
has anybody like we do like if I mess up
if I said some mess up stuff like this
you let your Vinnie just off like you
need to chill out Pat said something Tom
said something he's paying all these
people bro and you can say he'll get yo
his attitude is volatile if you say
something that he doesn't like you're
fired bro you're dumb no he doesn't have
uh yo chill out he has all Yes man he
doesn't have anybody going yo relax you
just lost what two billion dollars how
much more You're Gonna Keep Going how
much more because they're all losing
money bro yeah all his people his team
it's a wrap you can't you know it's bad
when Alex Jones is distancing himself
from you oh my God you are too extreme
that's that's when you know it's over
that's all Jones multiple times
told Kanye well you're not a Nazi
supporter right right buddy right I love
Adam you know you know how I take this
uh Elon Musk response I take the Elon
Musk response that he's done
he's just moving eyes like the cement
stop it like done with Kanye yeah it's
like it's just too much it's a little
too much let's just move on and he's he
he sounds like just the basic customer
service representative saying what he's
supposed to say to just move on and not
create it's almost like he's trying to
help him not react to anything else you
know I said something a couple like not
even a couple weeks ago I think I said
this a week ago where I said Connie I
think it's time for you to take a month
off of social media say no to to all
podcasts including Peabody podcast just
don't do any podcasts for a month just
take a break away from everybody and go
do some thinking everybody's got to do
it pastors do it business owners do it
military leaders do it you know parents
have to do it sometimes relationship you
gotta get away and decide how you're
gonna come back from this because this
is not a good look when you become too
addicted to wanting to get attention you
say stuff and at this point
um it's it's very disturbing is going
through I just think he needs to take a
break from everybody for about a month
and surround yourself with a few people
you love you trust that will not tell
anybody who are willing to privately
call you on your [ __ ] I don't know
if it's going to happen or not but I
think Elon Musk is like and the beauty I
don't even have time and the beauty with
the country is Pat if and you killed it
if he stays the beauty about this
country stay away six months a year come
back fresh I apologize be genuine this
is America everybody comes back bro
everybody that's just jacked up can
couldn't come back if they're genuinely
sorry but he's just every week is just
something every day it's like something
else something else something else like
bro go away for a little while I think
he is is digging the hole deeper and
deeper every time and I fully agree with
Pat but I know you're an odds guy Pat
what are the odds that he actually heeds
your advice and just says you know what
right you're Pat you're right Pat let me
take some time off and cool down for a
little bit I'm putting that at zero
percent there there's two different
things there is accidental there's
intentional decisions we make accidental
is somebody in your family dies you
choose to change you know
Force change is your girl breaks up with
you publicly it's humiliation you have
to change you lose everything you have
to change intentional is very hard to do
force all of us do it okay all of us do
it but intentional is the hardest thing
to ever do and change because you have
to choose to do it and I don't know if
he's intentionally going to change but I
guarantee you he's going to be forced to
change and that guarantee of being
forced to change will be because
something's going to happen to his life
you're going to either see the the kid
coming up to him saying Daddy you got to
stop this is too much I'm getting issues
in school you're making life harder one
of the kids has to say that don't I
don't want to be spending time with you
I want to take a break with you it's
going to drive him insane a parent a
parent who loves their kids and I
believe that this guy loves his kids I
really believe this guy loves his kids
fully and it's not everybody but some
every parent loves their kids no they
don't there's a lot of people that are
deadbeat fathers who step away if they
really love their kids why would they be
away from the kid for nine years so I
really think this guy loves his kids and
I think the the change is going to be
one of his kids I don't know how old how
old is the oldest kid that he has North
Northwest at probably 10 years old I'll
just say nine or ten yeah I mean if Tico
came up to me saying something at that
age he I can't have a serious
conversation with both Dylan and Tico
I really think there's only one person
that can get him to do that it's his
oldest kid I don't know if that's gonna
happen or not he's probably gonna say
Kim's telling you that your mom told you
to say this it's going to be like that
anyways yeah one last question about
your opinion Pat you know a lot of
people are calling him crazy bipolar all
right you know there's a famous phrasing
yeah he's crazy like a fox yeah just
play Devil's Advocate because I'm sure
you're not a fan of what he's doing
if you could go into the mindset of
Kanye West yeah and justify this type of
behavior justify this type of lunacy
as a crazy as a fox type of methodology
what would his intentions let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question let
me let me just simplify it for you it's
very easy for us to sit here and trash
this guy or any of these guys so what is
the most humili you don't need to say
but I want you to go to everybody at
this table what's the most humiliating
thing that ever happened in your life go
there you don't need to say it I'm not
telling you to say it but just go there
we all have it did you kind of figure it
out got it okay now imagine if it's on
every article every news every podcast
every TV channel tell me how you feel
about it okay so actually think about
that right there that's what this guy's
going through a freaking Pete Davidson
took his wife his wife went with him who
is Pete Davidson and the league of Kanye
for contributing to society in the world
I mean Pete Davidson Kanye is the music
he's done the art has created the you
know the not not taking anything away
from Pete but there's a difference in
talent and value to the world right when
so so in his mind he's sitting there
saying my girl left me for that
he's publicly humiliated and he's trying
to recover from that embarrassment but
the approach is taken is is not the
approach I would take so anyways I I
don't uh uh I feel very bad and I don't
like it at all it makes me feel very
uncomfortable and I wish I could talk to
the guy but I don't think he's in a
place that he would be willing to talk
to anybody and take counsel from anybody
I don't think he trust anybody and by
the way for the right reasons so go talk
to your 10 year old kid and see what
your 10 year old kid tells you because
that kid loves you
it's your blood anyways so can we do
this last story I want to do with
sandbankment free before we wrap it up
so this story came out by the way this
is a real story I tweeted this yesterday
I got one minute on this story Sam
bankman freed okay this is from Vice
is trying to find the guy who did this
this is not a joke by the way this is
not Babylon B just so everybody knows
this is real I posted this yesterday and
I posted the link to the article
yesterday Rob I'm gonna send it to you
post a link to the article because this
is not the real article article I just
sent you from Vice this is on Vice okay
just go to the link okay go right there
to Twitter it's right below that tweet
that I send out go a little lower go
below that you'll see right there click
on that click on that right there this
is vice
Simon was trying to find the guy who did
this okay
Tom and I were talking about this
yesterday Tom's like what he sounds like
O.J Simpson
the Killer's still out there yeah yeah
I'm gonna spend the rest of my life
trying to find out who killed he's gonna
write a book pack I didn't do it but if
I die you know every Golf Course a strip
club till I find it either this guy is
naive he's dumb he's oblivious he he he
thinks the world is dumb or he's a
psychopath a sociopath but he's one of
those things you decide who this guy is
I don't know how he did it yesterday
Michael said I was talking about this
guy we're on the podcast together with
him shout out to Michael Saylor every
time you listen to this guy your brain
gets muscular head gets bigger because
all your muscles are working but uh yeah
this guy this guy knows exactly what he
did Scott knows exactly what he did and
there's a lot of people that have his
back that are trying to protect him
because all the leaks of texts and
messages and emails and you know
whatsapps and all that if that stuff
leaks I guarantee you a lot of political
leaders are going to be very very
embarrassed by being tied to a guy like
this yeah well it's 38 million dollars
to the DNC and in the close end
candidates the super close in candidates
it was 38 million that is public and is
known about and so you've got people
like Maxine Waters who are out there
they do not want to be accused of taking
money from the mob that's a political
problem that's as old as the hills you
take it from a developer the developer
is really dirty he gets arrested you run
for the hills because oh I didn't take
that money from my campaign that's the
game being played here anyways we got to
find out who did this yeah we got to
find the person and shout out to his mom
for encouraging him to not take personal
responses 12 years ago the article blame
is overstated yeah okay so uh tomorrow
we have a weird podcast it could be like
an Antonio Brown type of a podcast and
we're gonna go live with the podcast we
were thinking about pre-recording and
then going live the next day but we're
actually going to go live with the
podcast tomorrow once it's posted and
you find out who it is and what it's
about something tells you many of you
guys are going to be interested in the
podcast tomorrow stay tuned looking for
and having it with us there I think you
got something going on I got I got to
give a plug for this massive podcast I'm
going to be on later today I'm going to
be on
funny how Vincent oshana's podcast four
you and I will chop it up 4pm live
crazy yes uh Dexter Tom is 100 Dexter
I'm talking about you right off the rip
the economy is my drunk by the way by
the way let me read this let me give a
shout out to Tom very quick DL Saint I
really want to know podcast gave a
hundred dollars today and he said great
show guys when will Tom have a show on
this platform if that's not going to
happen Tom where can I find you LOL keep
leading from the front gentlemen Tom
will be introducing a podcast here very
soon about business and we cannot find
we cannot wait to launch that and
introduce that to you guys so DL saying
be patient is coming very soon thank you
for the Super Chat 23 is gonna be a very
very very very big Good Year we're
excited about it the pbd podcast ladies
and gentlemen 500 000 we're gonna do a
live one with everybody at 500 000. take
care everybody bye bye